welche ziele im leben hast du 100.000
abonnenten auf youtube lebensziel
erreicht
im final die complete jetzt kann ich in
ruhe sterben
danke schön das war es übrigens noch das
letzte video 100.000 abonnenten haben
lange darauf hingearbeitet
es ist endlich passiert deswegen heute
ein kleines kino video ich habe das noch
nie gemacht dass das erste mal dass ihm
ja fragen stellen konnte die ich heute
beantworten werde
los geht's
woher nimmst du deine informationen ich
lese sehr viel ich bin viel auf twitter
unterwegs auf reddit hab mein google
news feed quasi darauf ausgerichtet dass
alle meine sachen die ich mir die mich
interessieren da auftauchen und das sind
halt viele sachen die in den videos auch
auftauchen
also das ist technik das sind die
zukunftstechnologien
das sind aktuelle wissenschaftliche
paper neuigkeiten durchbrüche alles in
diesem bereich was ich quasi mir täglich
angucke ist ein quasi später auch in den
videos das hat den großen vorteil dass
wenn ich ein skript obama schreiber dass
ich schon viele viele sachen die sie in
dem bereich unterwegs sind weiß dass ich
bei spiele einfach so aus dem stegreif
quasi nehmen kann und nicht mehr so
unglaublich viel recherchieren muss wenn
ich diese videos dann vorbereitung
wie lange brauchst du zur beantwortung
der fragen das ist ohne frage zu
beantworten drei sekunden komplett
unterschiedlich aber an und für sich
könnte man sagen ich brauche bestimmt
mal mindestens einen tag lang in zu
recherchieren um alle themen für das für
das thema relevante informationen zu
bekommen um artikel zu lesen & paper zu
lesen und diese informationen alle
zusammenzutragen und zu einem skript
nenne ich das zusammenzufügen dann
dauert ungefähr zwei drei stunden um
dieses skript dann auch aufzunehmen
dafür haben wir unser studio hier wo wir
das video drehen und dann dauert es
bestimmt noch mal mindestens zwei tage
im schnitt um die ganzen sachen nicht
gesagt habe zusammenzufügen in sinnvolle
reihenfolge zu bringen und auch
animationen zu machen dass dort dann
auch noch mal relativ lange zeit als
insgesamt kann man schon sagen
drei vier tage über mehrere leute
verteilt dauert das schon und dann gibt
es natürlich die videos die noch viel
viel aufwendiger sind wenn wir zum
beispiel unterwegs sind ich war letztens
beim info truck war in komplett
deutschland schon irgendwie unterwegs in
berlin in münchen habe der videos
integriert manchmal bin ich auf messen
ich war letztens in einem wendelstein
7-x einer kern fusionsanlage da fährt
man halt wirklich auch erstmal stunden
tag lang hin und wieder zurückdreht dann
da und hat sich noch kein wirkliches
scripps gemachten also es gibt
unterschiedliche auf wendigkeit stufen
für videos was hast du studiert ich habe
nach dem abitur direkt film studiert ja
sowas kann man studieren
in köln und hab das jetzt letztes jahr
abgeschlossen mit einem bachelor bin
jetzt also bachelor of arts ich habe
nicht studiert was irgendwie mit physik
oder naturwissenschaft zu tun hat das
höchste der gefühle ist mein physik
leistungskurs aber das meiste was ich
weiß recherchiere ich hatte mir bleiben
ist das grundverständnis von von physio
das meiste ja schwierig einfach und habe
eine spannende ich finde ich die thema
verspannt ich habe interesse dafür
und deswegen kann ich das glaube ich
auch ganz gut verstehen worum es da geht
man kann's auch deswegen gut erklären
was ist dein hauptberuf youtube mit
sicherheit nicht oder falsch
youtube ist in dem sinne mein hauptberuf
ich habe jetzt eine firma gegründet
trentino film und diese firma macht
verschiedene sachen produktionsfirma
aber wir machen auf jeden fall als eines
der haupt dinge die wir machen ist
doktor watson der youtube kanal muss es
nicht um das team auch mal ganz kurz
vorzustellen das hier ist manu bei uns
creative producer und das ist marian bei
uns für die produktion verantwortlich
und steht auch hinter der kamera der
macht schnitt und animationen von den
videos zusammen sind wir also wir haben
eine firma gegründet die also basiert
wie gesagt schon auf doktor watson
allerdings machen wir viele viele andere
sachen auch die irgendwie mit internet
und youtube und wissensvermittlung zu
tun haben also aktuell sieht gut aus und
machen spaß zusammen zu arbeiten und wir
werden weiterhin doktor watson machen
aber auch viele viele andere coole sache
machen
die nachkommastellen von pi kannst du in
32 31 41 59 26 14 15
6 7 1 4 1 59 65 39
man braucht ja auch nicht wirklich
wesentlich mehr als man konnte ja
ausrechnen glaube ich mit dabei bin ich
mich aber mit sehr wenigen stellen von
päpsten zu 30 oder sowas
38 da kann man den gesamten umfang des
universums auf die größe eines atoms
korrekt berechnen
alle zahlen dahinter brauchen wir nicht
und selbst haben die nasa arbeitet
glaube ich nur mit sechs
nachkommastellen von vier oder acht oder
so also wenig es selbst 10
man braucht mich so viele nachkommen
herstellen wie bist du zu youtube
gekommen aber da nicht mal was mit
klicks xoom also ganz ursprünglich
angefangen habe ich ja mit gaming videos
das wissen viele nicht ich habe ganz
frühjahr call of duty battlefield videos
gemacht ganz ganz früh durch das
allererste waren world of warcraft
montage habe ich früher gespielt dann
ging es darüber zu wissenschaft und
wissenschaft fand ich schon immer
faszinierend fand ich immer cool und
spannend ich habe gerne drüber
gesprochen und youtube für mich eine
möglichkeit über die themen die mich
faszinieren wo ich für brenner das quasi
dauer ist ein hobby zu machen und daraus
videos zu machen und ich glaube viele
leute die mich kennen wissen dass ich
sehr gerne über künstliche intelligenz
und über elektroautos darüber selbst
waren auto spreche ich habe meine
allerersten wissenschafts videos mit
oder bei christoph gemacht bei clixoom
und war damals praktikant da genau ich
habe die skripte geschrieben ich habe
die videos geschnitten und irgendwann
ist christoph mal gehabt krank gewesen
aber auch in einer konferenz deswegen
bin ich eingesprungen ist habt dann mich
vor die kamera gestellt und ein video
auf klicks um gemacht und dann
irgendwann noch eins und noch eins
jugend nichts über meine eigene serie
auf dem kanal bekommen die spots all das
habe ich halbes jahr lang gemacht über
20 videos gemacht die videos gibt es
auch noch die kann man sich angucken
falls ihr mal die anfänge von der
flotten sehen wollte und dann vielleicht
hat man schon raus gehört habe ich auf
what's on doktor watson mit einem h
hinter dem wege macht clever das war der
start des kanals das war im august 2015
jetzt über dreieinhalb jahre her und das
ist daraus geworden
denkst du nicht auch dass das deutsche
schulsystem endlich mal neu gestaltet
werden müsste bin kein pädagoge deswegen
kann ich das nicht genau beurteilen
allerdings kann ich mir schon vorstellen
dass das was aktuell machen nicht
optimal ist um kinder auf das leben
vorzubereiten um faszinationen zu
fördern um wissenschaftler heraus zu
bilden oder halt einfach nur
funktionsfähige mitglieder der
gesellschaft zu fördern wie man das
jetzt genau macht was man da jetzt
machen sollte das sollten glaube ich
andere leute entscheiden ich habe
definitiv ein paar ideen aber wenn wie
gesagt excel auf keinen fall experte was
ich mir nur wünschen würde ist dass der
beruf des lehrers höher gestellt sein
sollte also im aktuellen in deutschland
ist lehrer seien allein schon zum
beispiel durch die bezahlung ja nicht
besonders hoch ist nicht besonders
angesehen und das sollte man eigentlich
sollten die klügsten köpfe der
gesellschaft die nächsten klügsten köpfe
der gesellschaft ausbilden
viele lehrer über die meisten lehrer
machen das sehr sehr gut und wir machen
unglaublich viele arbeit und die werden
teilweise von systemen aufgehalten und
werden zurückgehalten was unglaublich
schade ist dass man sich teilweise so
stark an lehrpläne halten muss aber gut
wie gesagt sind wir mal ehrlich es gibt
definitiv menschen die werden perfekte
lehrer geworden machen es aber nicht
weil man zu wenig geld dafür bekommt wie
erklärst du deinen erfolg das geht ganz
einfach mit den sechs tipps die jetzt in
meinem buch kaufen köln los kaufen sie
meine sechs tipps zum erfolg das buch
wahlgang als sandra kinkel brecht
verkauft was interessantes thema also
ich selber bin auch jemand der viel
prokrastination sagt im englischen also
der sachen aufschiebt teilweise bis zum
letzten moment oder dass der letzte
moment eigentlich schon verstrichen ist
wenn also andere leute vor allem leute
geben
jetzt wo andere leute vor allem auch
leute die mir nahestehen abhängig davon
sind dass ich was pünktlich mache damit
sie weiter arbeiten können hilft mir das
auf jeden fall einfach weil ich den
eindruck habe sondern da kann ich
einfach nur sagen selbstdisziplin also
es gibt nicht das heißt es sollte nicht
motivation heißen sondern disziplin
autoren haben wir zum beispiel den trick
gesagt ich schreibe jeden tag sechs
seiten
ob das gute seiten sind oder schlechte
seiten ob die am nächsten tag wieder
umgeschrieben werden müssen ist egal
jeden tag werden sechs seiten
geschrieben oder 10.000 zeichen oder 500
worte oder was auch immer es egal also
viele autoren und leute die so in diesem
bereich arbeiten haben diese regel und
das ist einfach unglaublich wichtig dass
man in diesem rhythmus und diese
disziplinen reinkommt es gibt keine
ausreden keine möglichkeit irgendwie
drum herum zu kommen und dann macht man
aus welche bereiche der wissenschaft
werden sich demnächst am meisten
entwickeln
ok also eine der größten bereiche ist
auf jeden fall künstlicher intelligenz
da wird auf jeden fall sehr sehr viel
passieren da passiert ja gerade schon
einiges und ich glaube der große
durchbruch wird uns dann noch mal in
einem ganz anderem einen anderen bereich
befördern und die künstliche intelligenz
ist aktuell noch nicht wirklich in
vielen bereichen noch nicht wirklich der
ersatz des menschen
es kann aber sehr gut sein dass wir da
bald hinkommen und das wäre auf jeden
fall ein bereich wo die wissenschaft
eine große diskussion der gesellschaft
hervorrufen könnte
was denkst du zur unsterblichkeit
unsterblich kann man nicht sein egal wie
man seinen körper umbaut klarmann stück
vielleicht dann nicht mehr durch
altersschwäche oder durch demenz im
gehirn oder was auch immer aber man kann
immer irgendwie sterben also spätestens
wenn der server auf dem dein bewusstsein
gespeichert ist wenn der strom ausgeht
bist du trotzdem tod und allerspätestens
beim hitzetod des universums sind wir
alle tot
[Musik]
also jetzt es gibt sehr selbst schnell
ins philosophische rein aber ich finde
es eigentlich sehr gut an also nil ist
muss man nichts zu glauben oder
zumindest daran zu glauben dass die
regeln des universums so sind wie sie
sind dass es keinen sinn des lebens gibt
dass es keinen tod kein leben nach dem
tod gibt dass wir alle sterben werden
darüber hinwegzusehen einfach cool ich
habe jetzt hier meine 60 70 jahre auf
der erde ich habe hier menschen und
tiere mit dem ich zusammen lebe ich kann
nur der beste mensch sein der ich sein
kann ich kann mein eigenes leben das
leben meiner mitmenschen so glücklich
wie möglich machen das glück maximieren
das einzige was man sinnvollerweise tun
kann und dann ist gut man kann ich nicht
machen alles andere steht außerhalb
meiner macht ich bin halt auch einfach
nur ein haufen kohlenstoff atome und
noch ein paar andere sachen
aber mir bin ich nicht alt bist du und
wo kommst du her ich bin 23 und lebe in
köln bin aber eigentlich düsseldorfer
und für die die es nicht wissen bis loch
in köln mögen sich nicht besonders
deswegen bin ich eigentlich ist hier so
ein bisschen undercover und werde
ständig mit tomaten beworfen wenn ich
sage dass ich das sogar bin ist nicht
mal keiner
eine ganz schlimme die qualität die auch
nicht wirklich schlimme ist aber es geht
es ist das halt viel sport und so in das
lokal realität hat ohne das erste gäbe
unter den ersten menschen die den mars
besiedeln wurde ich glaub ich schon mal
gefragt
ehrlich gesagt nein ich mag es hier sehr
gerne ich finde das unglaublich spannend
was da passiert wundert auch die leute
die sich dafür anmelden
allerdings viele dieser dieser programme
sind ja auch ein ticket ohne wiederkehr
man verhindern man weiß man kommt nicht
mehr zurück
und selbst wenn man das space ex
programm sich anschaut wo ja gesagt wird
man kommt dann auch kostenlos wieder
zurück ist nicht garantiert
und das ist dass das gegengewicht dazu
man muss das ja mal aufwiegen das ging
nicht dazu ist natürlich ehre und und
der ruhm dass man als erster mensch oder
einer der ersten menschen auf dem mars
ist hat war es auf jeden fall aber da
bin ich doch glaube ich dann noch ein
bisschen zu gemütlich und mag dass hier
mit sauerstoff und essen zeigt uns doch
mal dein studio
dafür sei jetzt leider keine zeit habe
ihr könnt gerne mal auf instagram gucken
doktor watson
da mache ich häufiger mal wie ein
tessins stories auf instagram zeige das
studio hinten bei unserer arbeitsmoral
was wir sind den ganzen tag über
und immer wenn etwas spannendes gibt
wenn wir zum beispiel auf dem dreh sind
oder wenn wir auf irgendwelchen coolen
messen sind bot spannende sachen zu
sehen sind dann hole ich meinem handy
raus und mache incentives und das kann
man sich da ganz viel angucken wie kann
man dich unterstützen das ist eine gute
frage und die beste möglichkeit ist
patrick petschel ist quasi kickstarter
oder indigo nur monatlich die können die
mich unterstützen und dafür behind the
scenes videos sehen im abspann meiner
videos genannt werden und sogar videos
vor allen anderen bekommen katrin hilft
uns mehr und bessere doktor watson
videos zu machen also ganz ganz lieben
dank an alle menschen die uns da
unterstützen ihr seid einer der gründe
dafür dass wir jeden tag das machen
können was wir lieben
ansonsten an alle die das video geguckt
haben vielen lieben dank fürs zuschauen
bleibt neugierig
[Musik]